in recent years have been a kind of
movement of highlighting some of the
hypocrisy instead of highlighting the
racism the fact that many of the
founding fathers were slave owners that
kind of thing uh sort of highlighting
from the current
uh ethics of our world uh showing that
many of the people involved in the war
on each side were evil what do you think
about that perspective on history I
think it's super valuable I think we
should expose the the gap between ideals
and practice but that doesn't mean we
should throw away the great people who
were also Hypocrites because everyone
I've studied is a hypocrite I'm a
hypocrite I think I'm a pretty good
father luckily my son is an even better
mother but uh uh there are parts of me
there I mean I often find myself telling
our children to do things that I didn't
do right yeah but they're smart and they
recognize that and they learn something
from that so let's not cover over
the hypocrisy but let's not throw people
away for being hypocritical here's my
view of Thomas Jefferson which is
similar to my view of Abraham Lincoln
right these are incredibly insightful
thoughtful people who added so much to
our country
but they also created flawed systems
and one of Link one of excuse me
Jefferson's flaws was even though he saw
all the evils of slavery he was a
terrible farmer and he could not imagine
living the lifestyle he lived without
slaves he could never work his way out
of that but that doesn't make the
Declaration of Independence less
valuable in fact it makes it more
valuable there's more that we can learn
from that and to me
on the hypocrisy side many of the people
that participate in cancel culture and
these kinds of movements that call
everything as racist uh and so on
sometimes they're highlighting uh
properly the evils in our current
Society
but the hypocrisy they have is not
realizing if they were placed in Germany
in the 40s if they were placed in the
position of being a white Christian
during slavery at the fighting of this
country they would do the same thing
they would do the evils that are not
criticizing
most of them that it takes a truly
heroic human to think outside to be
aware of all the evils going on Assad
around you and take action it's easy now
on Twitter to call people as racist
what's hard is to see the racism when
you're living in it and your well-being
is funded by it yep I think that's right
I think to analyze ourselves and look
honestly in the mirrors very hard I also
think I make this point in actually all
of my books
um the real and it's an Eli visel point
that a lot of the evil in our world is
the evil of silence and just looking
away
and and one form of that on Twitter is
just hitting like
yeah uh it's it's a cheap way of
pretending you're you're doing something
that's important right after the Civil
War there's all sorts of bad stuff that
happens I talk about it a lot there
always are people there who could stop
it
most people are not responsible for the
bad activities but most don't do
something to stop it
and when I say do something I mean
really do something yeah really and
that's it's also to push back in the
pushback
silence on Twitter is not what Eli
wazelle was talking about
so sometimes silence on Twitter is the
courageous action because you wait and
think and learn and have patience to
truly understand the situation before
you take actual action not participate
in the outrage crowds on Twitter the
hysteria of cancellation what's hard to
do is to speak up when everybody else is
silent right that's what's hard to do
right and to speak up against those who
you thought were on your side yes
exactly good luck to those on the left
who speak up against the left uh and the
same good luck to those on the right who
speak up against the right
it's a lonely place it's a it's a
painful place that's why walking in the
center is tough you get attacked by both
sides yeah so it's a wonderful wonderful
uh journey and you know what what's
interesting to me uh and what I learned
writing this book every book is a
journey what I learned in this in the
laboratory of this book right
was a lot of those figures who do stand
up
uh even in their own lifetime they don't
get the accolades they deserve but they
make a difference and that that's maybe
not enough Comfort uh because you want
to see benefits in your own lifetime but
I think it really matters and many of
the figures I talk about were not even
well known in their time so you can make
a difference you do impart something
small in the universe that can grow into
something better and we shouldn't forget
that yeah that's why I admire a boxer
the horse I will work harder even if he
gets sent to the slaughter by the evil
pigs
you're on Orwell today I love how much
recently I mean uh animal farm is one of
my favorite my favorite books I've been
recently I've just I'm rereading 1984
now uh it's been politicized that book
in general yeah but to me it's a love
story it is a love story that there's uh
the like love is the like it's a story
of an oppressive government it's a real
estate and uh the nature of Truth being
manipulated by War time so on but the
the Beacon of Hope in the human heart
that pulls you out that wakes you up in
a world like that is a love of another
human being it's Transcendence I totally
agree my understanding you would know
better than I would is that it's now a
best-selling book in Russia again 1984
yeah it's actually being downloaded more
there was a piece on NPR I heard about
this actually yeah yeah well I hope it's
because they're looking for love that's
what I was just gonna say hopefully not
in all the wrong places
hey there's no such thing as the wrong
places but that's that's my opinion I'm
the one that showed up naked and drunk
to your classroom I'm still surprised
that with you
I was wearing a wig I'm sorry